quarante deux années séparent ces deux
hommes mais une conviction les réunit le
communisme à l'occasion du centenaire du
parti ils reviennent sur les moments
forts du pcf en franche comté
frédéric bernabé ancien élu à vesoul
adhère au parti rouge après mai 68 il
n'a pas oublié le passage de georges
marchais dans notre région c'était le
dernier dirigeant ouvriers du parti
communiste français
et quand il est venu en 1980 juste avant
la présidentielle en franche comté
il avait amené dans sa musette
électorale des grandes là aussi conquête
le développement sur l'aîné d'énergie
les transports etc
ça a été quelque chose d'extraordinaire
en france-comté autres figures
communistes qui a marqué la région
martial bourquin il était premier
secrétaire de la fédération pcf du doubs
avant de rejoindre finalement les rangs
des socialistes
en 1998 son rang la changer moi j'ai
fait le choix de la combe des
convictions
j'ai fait le choix de la fidélité à mon
parti et ne pas privilégier ma carrière
et martial bourque almeida fait d'autres
choix celui de de sa carrière à 25 ans
mathieu gilbert n'a pas connu
personnellement ces hommes politiques
il retient surtout de l'histoire
communiste franc comtoise une mesure
sociale fars il ya eu aussi besançon que
la terre de création du rsa avec à
l'époque donc plutôt des socialismes on
a aussi tout une toute une culture
économique
de réflexion économique avaient ensemble
ça c'est des choses qui marquent un
petit peu le territoire
un siècle après sa création au congrès
de tours le parti communiste subsiste
pourtant vu comme l'une des forces
majeures au lendemain de la guerre
le pcf peine aujourd'hui à recueillir +2
3% des suffrages
son plus grand défi est désormais de
reconquérir l'électorat
[Applaudissements]